[Music]
with over 15 films and 2
billion at the box office comedian candy
black has brought laughter to our lives
but america's sweetheart hit me where it
hurt
isn't so sweet anymore
we really need you to go into hair and
makeup right now miss black
okay everybody let's flush this turd
down the toilet
we're gonna do a rehearsal again with a
stand-in candy and i've been together
for years
but my true passion is acting what's
your secret to success
i guess i believe in boundaries
today hollywood's class clown back off
please
has fallen to a new low the judge has
sentenced her to 90 days
in rehab you shouldn't have to go to
rehab unless someone else goes in my
place
someone who looks a lot like me what
my name is candy and i am an alcoholic
this must be a real wake-up call for you
a big hollywood hot shot
here's a tip don't mix fentanyl bennies
and heroin
take it from crow in the rehab game i
feel like a fat amy winehouse
the today show once an interview lewis
is getting offers for
personal appearances i could stand in
for you we could split the money
sure i seem to like being candied more
than i ever did
people love a redemption story ooh we're
so glad she's back
[Music]
so the person that i've been dealing
with these last couple of weeks is the
stand-in not you
i mean she looks like me your voice is
uh you sound
like no this is the real me candy black
is here tonight to apologize that's what
i'm most sorry for
she looks amazing i need to know who did
that nose
[Music]
you got to do this film i can't do it i
think you can absolutely dive head first
from a bale of hay into a pile of cows
hit me where it hurts cut okay let's go
again
you